hi I'm Greg I'm John we're gonna watch
the trailer for slight the bloom house
movie know nothing about it John shut up
don't tell me anything you know I don't
know any blue mouse so you're gonna suck
the dick of this video hey man you gotta
keep my job
I highly doubt the legitimacy of my
employment hangs on this train as you
can see there's no string you know
coolness uh Holly you can grab it Alex
Oh Holly gonna suck should do that oh
okay do those fingers ready you do magic
my dad passed while back and my mom
passed last year it's just me Melissa 15
my life
[Music]
so you have been going good
I've been handed me for primaries when
we move into our backyard it's not
selling like I don't exist we gonna pay
him a little visit
talk to him buddy oh [ __ ] turn into
something I wouldn't have a scandal for
never taught a kid danger's I just wish
I can rotate it to enable it with a
better school so I know bad people
you gotta my money back I gave you a job
when you needed it most
not you you and every person you know
happening rather we need to worry about
just want me to go on some project
I don't know idea how'd it happen I'm
gonna help you figure this out
like an amateur
I can do something lower let's see oh my
god I mean more power
this is imperfect is it
a lot of things are alive that attract
these various only I know we can do
whatever we want if we just silly babe
ah now law of attraction and energy you
know the players controlling everything
is through energy and he really believes
he can do it so that's how he's able to
move everything because he's managed to
really hone in on the secret
so much secret is so much secret do a
regular secret change his life I don't
know why hasn't changed the
circumstances of working with these
gangsters it's really even a more
positive life yeah and I totally get it
I get it every big plot hole what
happened there Matt is pretty cool yeah
this looks cool again I have not sown
this this is exactly dr. stranger with a
black eye right it's like the exact same
movie but one of the magic superheroes
exactly move I guess I understand the
comparison there yeah I mean it's
exactly the same visually and everything
doesn't yeah totally like a tall
register and a dick Cumberbatch boy I
got your Nicholas I mean it's very
convincing but a little bit I don't know
yeah controversial Oh homie yeah I mean
my favorite parts of the trailer or when
he's like wooing over that one chick
yeah cuz I'm like ah that's not I won't
be that guy how cool would that be if I
just had some magic powers and some hot
girl would like home so loud by you you
must be an amazing person all because I
can move stuff in my mind you know be
pretty cool it would be what I want I
want to be those more how can be very
responsible although her character
doesn't look very layered this whole
trailer she's just like whoa wow you are
like really involved maybe yeah well and
this is what makes me curious about this
trailers it seems like it has potential
to have some pretty good character stuff
as well you know like this kind of looks
like one of those you know like a truer
sort of sci-fi thriller ish that has
nothing to say and has sort of a cool
high concept idea right all right so I
didn't yeah but I can I get what you at
least from the trailer yeah I go to mean
I obviously feel like the trailer might
be a little misleading in tonin
I feel like trying to build it up to be
like this crazy like suspenseful
thriller yeah
when I feel like there's probably gonna
be more to explore here than just ABC
plot points yeah that's what I'm hoping
for now I feel like that
it was hinting at stuff like that but
they're trying to make it short as I
could appeal the massive somebody help
me a lot more of a like a carrot like I
feel like we're going to really get a
good character out of this main guy who
is called Jacob Latimore Jacob Latimore
yeah cuz like watching his character in
this trailer a lot of these shots are in
just kind of looking emotional don't you
did enough yeah I feel like this is
probably the sort of one those like
indie movie but with higher concepts
yeah exactly
magic we're better my good character
scene and that's honestly what I hope
for out of this movie me is just a
viewer you know because the later part
of the trailer actually for me I was
like I really don't want to see all this
out of context you know when he's really
having that showdown at the end with the
gangster that's that's what i meant by
how this is looking they're trying to
make the trailer like suspenseful like
claw point a be any guy gets converse
realized so you can do something good
and now he's going after the bad yeah
yeah so I you know I I do hope this
falls on the more like oh so a strange
you know strange drama thing I suppose
I'll be like an inspiring message of
belief by the end because I feel
especially with that ending notes like
you get such a suspenseful thriller yeah
and you can do anything if people leave
it you know yeah it makes me wonder yet
where the movies hard is kind of but
exactly
it's intrigued me enough that I
definitely want to see it and I heard I
think they acquired this out of a
festival or something I read in the
trades or whatever but I heard good
things from its festival screening all
right cool cool what other magic tricks
can he do I ought to be so sick if you
could do magic like take a girl's
clothes off with just your mind there we
go see it was going than single kiddo
this is happening it wasn't where he's
going to do it okay well maybe long as
everyone's on board for didn't be like
everything on a first almighty which is
pleasuring Jennifer Aniston
moving in a breaking of that just
just in ten minute we're gathered in the
middle yeah I think that's really what
would it mean alright y'all what do you
think of the trailer did you like it if
you did let me know if you didn't let
John know follow him on Twitter and
Instagram reasons Jerry you can
subscribe later real regions if you'd
like to and if you just don't like gloom
house in general you could go [ __ ]
about it at facebook.com slash bloom
house and if you like the real rejects
you can tell us at facebook.com slash no
real risk it was colicky emotional media
manager both and shadows and pyro Magnus
the real magician the real black
magician mr. new Twitter handle this is
a neat order to have a black magician
the real black magician I'll show you
all how to get 1 million subscribers